we're back
police in indiana rescued a girl from
the basement of a man's home
after they say she was kidnapped and
sexually assaulted investigators are now
looking into whether that same suspect
is behind the unsolved murders of two
teens in delphi
best friends 14 year old liberty libby
german and 13 year old abigail williams
were last seen hiking on the delphi
historic trail on valentine's day 2017.
their parents report him as missing when
they didn't show up at their pickup
location
the next day volunteers discover their
bodies in a wooded area
investigators say the girls left a very
important clue behind
indiana state police say german recorded
a suspicious man following them
and someone can be heard saying guys
down the hill
well there's specific information in
this investigation
that we're not releasing that if it
comes to our attention
we're going to know that's a good tip we
need to really pay close attention to
that
no arrest has been made yet but a case
just 15 minutes away
is drawing new attention james chadwell
ii was arrested last week in lafayette
indiana
police say a missing ten-year-old girl
was found in the basement of his home
with multiple injuries including bite
marks on her body
according to police chadwell invited her
into his home to pet his dogs
when he allegedly trapped her and tried
to strangle her chadwell is facing
charges of attempted murder
child molestation and kidnapping the
local sheriff's department is now
reportedly looking into chadwell
to see if he has any connection to the
delphi murders people want to make the
assumption that the voice saying down
the hill
it belongs to the person that's captured
in the image
from the cell phone that's not
necessarily the case
we're not making any assumptions about
that we have more video
we have more audio but it is specific to
the investigation
and that's why it's not being released
at this time
here to discuss this true crime
mysteries defense attorney imran ansari
and co-host terry austin
terry do you think these crimes could be
connected by the same person
and why you know i think they might be
connected i will have to see what the
evidence says
but there are certain similarities the
fact that one lafayette
is 15 minutes from delphi it could very
well be
that this individual traveled back and
forth
they said that the young girl in the
basement had strangulation marks and
while the police aren't saying
that libby and abby had strangulation
marks there is some speculation that
they might have very well been strangled
and the biggest piece of evidence i
think connecting this individual to the
two girls
is the fact that the sketch looks a lot
like the video so it could very well be
connected we'll have to see what the
evidence says
yeah it looks close unsure whether or
not be beyond a reasonable doubt close
but we'll see how that plays out imran
these girls quick thinking may have left
clues of their own killer
what are officers likely looking at to
see if there's a connection between
that killing and this uh alleged
attempted murder
well we heard the officer talking about
that there's uh additional
video and audio and they're going to see
if how they can connect it
possibly to this suspect and you have to
look at the
commonalities between the two uh alleged
crimes
and you have uh the victims are are
young female
children uh you have geographic
similarity
uh and there are some similarities in
terms of the modus operandi and i think
they're going to be looking for those
connections
to see if there are in fact the same
suspect terry what do you think
geography mo uh
just opportunity and that picture i mean
imran and i both looked at each other
when you saw that picture we're like uh
kind of close
what do you think i think the
prosecution is going to pursue this
because they
are looking for someone it's been some
time now and they want to solve this
case so
i think if they find enough evidence
they're going to go ahead and make that
connection and bring a case
absolutely going to find some sort of
corroboration maybe emma what do you
think dna
fingerprints could that be helpful here
sure i think they're going to look at
the forensic evidence they have in terms
of the videos from the first incident
and connect that if they can with this
suspect and with this
second incident and also we're going to
look at probably the testimony from this
young woman who
is in fact alive thankfully and see if
that's going to also corroborate
what we have evidence-wise from the
first incident we'll see when we come
back an alleged murderous family of six
why one rogue member of the tight-knit
family may send them all to jail
next